Okay Michael, you've called my bluff. You, you said
I've left out the most important parts, and you
are right. So, I'm going to tell you ,how to
construct the most important parts. Let's start, with the distribution.
So, let's start with the base case, and that
is the distribution, at the beginning of time, D
sub one. So, this distribution, is going to be
over each of the examples and those examples, are ,indexed,
so, over i. And I'm simply going to
set that distribution, to be uniform. So, how
many examples do we have, Michael? Let's pick,
let's pick a letter. Let's call it n.
>> Okay.
>> Why not, cause we do that for everything else and I'm
going to say that for every single one of the examples they happen one
over int times, that is uniform distribution. Now, why do I do that,
because, I have no reason to believe, for the purposes of this algorithm,
that any given example, is better ,than any other example,
more important than any other example, harder than other example
or anything else. I know nothing. So, see if you
can learn over all of the examples. You with me?
>> Yeah, cause I feel like if it
actually solves that problem, we're just done. So [CROSSTALK]
>> [CROSSTALK] Yes and, and that's what you always want. But that's
the easy case. So I start out with uniform distribution, that's what you
usually do ,when you don't know anything. But, what are you going to
do ,while your in the middle? So, here's what I am going to
do Michael. At every time step T, I'm
going to construct, a new distribution, Dis of
T plus 1. Okay so, here's how we're
going to construct the distribution at every time step. Okay?
I'm going to create the new distribution, T plus 1 to be E for each example, I.
- to be the old distribution, and times T, times E to the minus alpha T, times Y
sub i, times H of sub T, of X of I, all divided
by Z sub T. [LAUGH] So that's pretty obvious right? [LAUGH]
So what do each of those terms mean? I mean ,I
know it's intuitively obvious ,even to the most casual observer, but ,let
me just try to explain what each of the parts mean.
So, we know that the D is our distribution and it's some
number, where, over all the examples, it adds up to one.
And it's a stand-in, we know, because I said this at the
beginning, for how important a particular ,example is, how
often we expect to see it. And that's the
trick that we're using with distributions. So, I'm going to
take the old distribution for an example, of, for
a particular example. And I'm going to either make
it bigger or smaller, based upon, how well, the
current hypothesis, does, on that particular example. So, there's
a cute little trick here, we know that h
of t always returns, a value ,of either minus one or
plus one, because ,that's how we define our training set, you
always have a label of minus one or plus one. So,
ht is going to return minus one or plus one for a
particular x sub i. Y of i which is the label
with respect to that example, is also always going to be plus
one or minus one. And alpha t is a constant, which
I will get into a little bit later just right now think
of it as a number. And so what
happens, Michael, if the hypothesis, at time t for
a particular example x of i agrees, with the
label, that is associated with that x of i?
>> Well, hang on, you say the alpha's a
number. Is it a positive number? A between 0
and 1 number? A negative number? What kind of
number? Does, does it not matter. I think it matters.
>> That's a good question. It, it
matters eventually. But right now, that number is
always, positive.
>> Positive, alright. So, like, a [UNKNOWN]. Almost
like a learning rate-y kind of thing, maybe.
>> It's a learning rate-y kind of thing, sort of.
>> Alright, so, good. So the y, okay, I see, I see. So, the y
times the h is going to be. 1 if they agree, and minus 1 if they disagree.
>> Exactly, so if they both say positive 1, positive 1 times positive 1 is 1.
If they both say negative 1, negative 1 times negative 1 is 1. So, it's exactly
what you say when they agree, that number is 1. And
when they disagree, that number is minus 1. Alpha Sub T,
which i define below, is always a positive number. You can
trust me on this. The error is always between 0 and
1. And it just turns out that the natural log of
1 minus a number between 0 and 1 over that number,
always gives you a positive number. And if you don't believe
me, you should play around with the numbers till you convince yourself.
So, that's going to be some positive number.
So, that means when they agree, that whole product
will be positive. Which means, you'll be raising
e to minus some number when they disagree that
product will be negative which means you'll be
raising e to some positive number. So, let's imagine
they agree. So you're going to be re
raising, e, to minus some number, what's going to
happen to the relative weight of d sub t of i?